哈喽大家好,我是贾明阳,KUSHA的Mantainer
今天由我来给大家分享一下
基于K8s的跨域隐私计算应用编排框架KUSHA
我将从以下三个方面进行介绍
第一部分会介绍一下我们为什么会需要KUSHA
第二部分会介绍一下KUSHA做了什么
第三部分介绍一下如何来去集成KUSHA
首先我们看一下就是一个应用
它要想运行起来会包含哪些因素
首先会包含应用本身
以及它依赖的一些系统库
以及它的启动的明阳参数和配置文件
也会涉及到一些磁盘的IO
CPU和Memory的一些资源占用
以及一些网络的要求
我们在做应用迁移和软件交付的时候
以上的这些因素我们都是要考虑进来的
不然的话可能就会遇到一个问题
就是在我的机器上能跑
但是在其他机器上是没有办法跑的问题
那么Darker和K8s的出现是解决了环境不一致的问题
比如说开发测试预发
还有生产环境存在一些差异
比如说操控系统 库版本 配置 网络设置等
导致应用在开发环境上运行是正常的
但到了实际的生产环境部署可能会运行失败
所以容器和K8s的出现解决了上述的问题
而容器可以将应用及其他的依赖
包括运行时库系统文件打包成了一个不可辨的镜像
然后K8s通过声明式的API
来定义应用部署时的期望状态
确保应用在任何的K8s进行上
只要应用的定义相同
它的运行行为就是高度一致的
所以K8s的出现是打破了开发和运维之间的一个壁垒
建立了一套开发与运维的统一的语言体系
让双方在同一个语言体系下进行协同
那联合计算应用也会遇到同样的问题
因为刚才介绍的是传统应用
这里边的联合计算应用指的就像多方安全计算
和联盟学习这种需要跨域的应用
我们可以简称为联合计算应用
比如说像右侧这张图一样
应用需要在Alice上面运行
同时也需要在Bob这边去运行
他们之间通过公网或者是专网专线进行通信
而不是应用仅在自己这一方运行
那这样的应用也是需要去解决它环境不一致的问题
也会遇到从开发到生产等遇到的一些类的问题
库莎的出现其实就是希望能够解决联合应用的以上出现的这些问题
另外这里边强调一点就是库莎是基于K3S去开发的
因为K3S它是一个轻量化的一个K8S
它的Banary的大角只有70兆
可以让我们库莎可以快速的轻量级的部出起来
我们简单对一个小节为什么需要库莎
就像传统应用需要K8S来解决环境不一致的问题一样
联合应用也需要库莎来去解决
从开发到生产环境的不一致的问题
库莎希望能够解决联合计算应用
由开发到生产所遇到的所有的共情问题
来加速联合计算应用的一个交付的过程
让应用能够快速的在生产上进行落地
第二部分我们来介绍一下库莎做了什么
首先作为联合计算应用是希望能够做到一个原子性的调度
就是All or Nothing
既要么两边同时被拉起
要么同时被销毁
就像下面这张图介绍的
就是应用可以同时运行或者是同时停止
不希望出现一方在运行
一方在停止的这样的状态
因为这样会导致一些资源的浪费
那库莎是怎样去实现这样的一个能力呢
简单的它的一个简单的一个实验模型
其实就是一个两阶段确认的这样的一个模型
类似于分布式事务的两阶段提交
首先比如说像这里边的这个例子
将S,Bob,Caro
他们三方需要共同来完成一个联合计算应用的一个任务
那首先阶段1会先在S,Bob,Caro进行资源的预占用
只有资源的预占用全部成功之后
才会去启动容器
如果资源预占用某一方失败了
那这个容器就不会去启动
从而进而把之前申请的资源再进行一个回滚
保证一个这样的原子型的调度
那具体的实现是因为库莎是基于KBS去做的实现
那KBS的scheduler它提供了可以在它调度过程当中
去插入用户定制的帕拉格印
所以实际上它不仅仅是两阶段的确认
而是多阶段的确认
比如说首先我们会去等待所有参与方的CRD创建成功
然后再去所有的参与方进行预留Node
之后再去所有方进行批准绑定
最终才是这个Bob和Node的绑定
然后才把容器拉起
来保证我们每一个调度的环节
都会做一个同步等待的一个操作
进而保证我们任务调度的原则性
库莎另外做的一个事情是跨越网络通信
跨越网络通信主要是做了两件事情
一个是会建立一个S到Bob的安全通信的通道
即会验证SBob的身份
同时这个通道是一个加密的传输
第二个是会让联合计算应用
像在本地局域网一样来访问一个跨越的网络
对于内部的应用来说
它就不需要感知这样一个复杂的跨越网络
具体是怎么做的呢
我们先看一下安全通信的通道
第一个是身份认证和加密的传输
下面这样例子是一个S到Bob的一个加密通道的一个
建联的一个简单的过程
首先S他会通过Bob的一个公要
对一个随机串进行加密发给Bob
因为是用Bob的公要进行加密的
所以Bob可以用他的私要进行解密
而且只有Bob能够解密拿到随机串A
Bob收到了这个请求之后
Bob也会对随机串B通过S的公要进行加密
然后S用他的私要进行解密之后拿到随机串B
最后S这边会把A和B进行一个拼接
作为通信认证的一个token
token它是有一个有效期的可以定时的刷新
同时SBob之间的通信也是可以进行端到端加密的
同这样方式建立一个安全通道
然后第二个是像访问本地局域网一样去访问跨域的网络
这里边举一个例子就是首先也是有S和Bob两方
然后希望做到的就是这个
这里边的SF指的就是secret flow
希望就是S这边的secret flow
可以直接能够配置一个Bob这边的一个域名
就可以直接能够访问到Bob这边的secret flow
具体的流程可以分为两个阶段
首先阶段一的话就是任务被拉起的时候
库沙会去创建一个secret flow的一个容器
同时也会注册一个service
在k8s里面注册一个service
这里边的service的例子就是像SF-task1.s.svc
然后Bob这边注册的service就是SF-task1.Bob.svc
这第一阶段端之后
然后会进入到实际的SF
它在发起请求的时候的一个具体流程
首先第一步我们可以看一下
我们举的是IS访问Bob这边的SF的一个例子
首先IS这边的SF
它会向SF-task1.Bob.svc
发送一个请求
就是直接用这样的一个域名去访问
它在发送消息的时候
因为发送的是一个域名
SF这边的容器它会先去
会去做一个域名解析
域名解析这里边会去请求到
库沙里边的一个模块
这个cods
然后会解析这个域名
会把这个域名解析到Gateway的IP
所以会进到第三步
也就是这个message实际上
是发给了本方的Gateway
然后本方的Gateway
会去解析SF-task1.Bob.svc这个域名
发现这个域名是Bob这边的域名
就是是发给Bob的请求
它就会借助上边
刚才介绍的安全通信的通道
会借助那个通道
把消息发给Bob的Gateway
然后Bob的Gateway这边
收到了这个请求之后
他发现这个是自己域内的一个请求
是访问自己本方的一个请求
那他也是会去先去请求本方的这个cods
然后将这个域名解析
成真实的SF的容器的IP
拿到这个真实的容器的IP之后
然后Gateway会把请求发给
Bob这一侧的SF的容器
进而完成了从IS的容器到Bob的容器
的这样的一个0签入的
应用的一个请求转发
同理如果Bob想给IS这边的SF发请求
道理也是一样的
只是一个相反的过程
扩大做的第三件事情是多运行时
可以多运行时的方式
去适配用户多种多样的部署环境
目前是支持了三种运行时
也就是一个应用的倾向
它可以以Round C的方式
就以容器的方式拉起来应用
也可以以KBS的Pod的方式来运行应用
也可以以进程的方式去运行应用
但是对于应用的开发者来说
他只需要提供Darker的倾向
具体采用哪种运行时
是根据用户实际的部署场景
下面我们来看一下
多运行时分别在什么场景下会去使用
首先如果是以物理机或者虚拟机的方式
去部署铺杀的时候
它分两种场景
一般是场景一
比如说是资源隔离
首先首选的我们是推荐是用户
以Round C的方式去运行应用
因为Round C它可以做到很好的资源隔离
可以让资源之间的
可以让应用之间的资源
可以互相没有抢占
第二个是
如果用户不希望我们的
构杀以高权限的
高级的权限去运行的话
我们可以去以Round P的方式去拉起
因为比如说像一些金融类的机构
它会对软件的部署权限
会有一些限制
所以在一些这类的机构
进行构杀安装的时候
可能会没有办法去
Round C的方式去运行
所以我们可以以
进程的方式去运行应用
以进程的方式去运行应用
它就没有办法去做到资源隔离
所以我们还是建议
首选选Round C
如果在Round C没有办法
去使用的情况下
才会去使用Round P
第二种部署场景
是KBS的部署
首先如果以KBS的部署
我们也是首选的
会推Round K的这种方式
也就是用用会
以POD的方式来被拉起
它同样它也可以做到
资源的隔离
也可以附用外部的部署的KBS
可以更好地进行
一个资源的利用
如果此类用户
也是它对构杀使用
KBS创建POD的权限有限制的话
我们只能推华常使用
Round P的方式进行运行
从而来适配这样的场景
所以其实我们构杀
做了这样三个运行时的原因
还是因为不同的用户
他们可能会采用
不同的部署环境
所以竟然我们要
根据实际的情况
进行运行时的一个选择
从而适配更多的部署环境
构杀做的第四个事情
是多数据源
因为就像刚才的例子当中一样
用户的部署环境
是多种多样的
同时用户它实际上
使用的数据源
可能也会是多种多样的
有些可能使用的是
本地的文件系统
有的可能使用的是
AWS3的对象存储
一些可能用的是
ODPS像这个Max Compute的
有一些可能使用的是
MySQL
或者是其他的这种
定制的数据源
那如果每一种应用
都会都对接一次
不同的数据源
那这个开发成本太大了
比如说这个应用
它包括像SF
SF serving
或者SQR
PIR
甚至一些其他的应用
他们没有办法
每一个都会去对接用户的
这种多种多样的数据源
所以户差提供了
一个Datemash的模块
只要用用对接了Datemash
就可以快速的享有
Datemash已经支持的数据源
对 同时就是
Datemash提供了一个 SDK
可以让用用可以快速的介入
第三个就是
我们也提供了
就在官网上
提供了数据源的介入的教程
就是用户也可以自己
去自行的对接一些
扩展的数据源
比如说现在
我们目前没有支持害物
用户可以参考我们的文档
去做一个害物的数据源的对接
同时就是
未来我们也会去
在Datemash当中
可以做一些集中的
权限控制
审期
锻炼续传
并化读写
都可以通过Datemash的
Io模块进行一些扩展
只要这个模块增加了
这样的能力
就可以让所有的应用
都可以快速的
想要到这样的能力
因为KUSHA是
基于KBS去开发的
所以KBS的一些
以有的能力
也可以在KUSHA当中
快速的去
奉用KBS的能力
比如说
KBS提供了一个
声明式API的能力
KBS对应用
提供了这种
高考用多副本的能力
或者是
可以让应用
可以快速的滚动的升级
以及可以对多个机器
这种大量的
机器集群的资源管理
这些能力
在KUSHA当中也是具备的
这里边
举两个
我觉得可能会
在实际的生产
交付的用户
可能会关心的
两个能力
也就是这个
应用版本管理当中的
一个是
应用如何升级
以及说
怎么保证
这个多版本共存的问题
这里边
主要是
应用升级
其实核心是
隔离的变化
其实
因为像应用的变化频率
它会更新和频率
会比较高
比如说
像SF
或者是SQL
这种应用
他们的更新频率会高
比如说
可以快速的增加一些
新的算子
或者新的特性的时候
可以把应用
做一个升级
那
KUSHA
因为它作为
底层的INFRA
它的变化频率
是可以低一点的
所以可以做到
就是在不升级
KUSHA的前提下
就可以快速的去更新应用
可以快速的去
享受一些
新的
应用的特性
这里边的
就是
应用升级
比如说
可以把SF
从唯一版本
可以快速的升级
到V2版本
具体的
升级方式
其实就可以
参考我们KUSHA API
里边的一个叫
更新
App Image的
镜像版本的
一个接口
具体的
这个接口
是在我们
KUSHA的官网
当中的API里边
会有相接的介绍
第二个
就是多版本的共存
这个多版本的共存
在
像这种
联合计算应用的
场景下
其实还是蛮常见的
比如说现在
还是有ISBOP
卡肉三个机构
然后
BOP它机
和IS有合作
同时跟卡肉
也有合作
IS这边
它使用的SF版本
是V1的
然后卡肉这边
使用的SF版本
是V2的
那BOP就可以
在自己这一侧
可以同时
部署两个版本
就是可以在
KUSHA里边
可以同时
运行两种
不同的版本
当它和IS合作的时候
运行的是SFV1的版本
然后和卡肉合作的时候
运行的是SFV2的版本
通过这样的方式
可以让不同机构之间
选择
合适的应用版本
进行
隐私计算应用
任务的一个构建
OK
我们对本节
做一个小节
KUSHA做了哪些事情
包括
第一个就是跨域的
任务协同
就是任务的
原子型调度
然后第二个
是跨域的网络通信
来让应用
可以像访问本地
网络一样
访问这个
跨域的网络
第三个是多余行时
包括让C
让P
让不同的用户
布置环境
第四个是
多数据源
来适配不同的用户
比如说是AWSS3的
或者是这个
ODPS的
能够适配
不同的数据源
第五个是
KBS的能力附用
让KBS也有的能力
可以在
KUSHA当中
快速地去使用起来
OK
第三部分
我们来介绍一下
是怎么去集成KUSHA
用户可以通过
KUSHA API来去集成KUSHA
像我们Cigaflow
这个大的Ripple
里面有一个模块
是Cigrepad
它就是
基于KUSHA API进行开发的
它是一个面向
用户的
在交互界面的
这样的一个平台产品
如果
用户想要开发
自己的一个平台产品
也可以基于
KUSHA API
去开发自己
的一个平台
我们在官方文档
和我们的官方课程当中
也有
详细的课程和文档
去介绍
如何来去通过
KUSHA API
去集成我们的KUSHA
第二种的集成方式
是将自己的应用
介入到KUSHA当中
目前KUSHA
是支持
言语体系内部的Cigaflow
Icql,psi, serving等应用
用户也可以将自己的
联合计算应用
介入到KUSHA当中
来去附用
KUSHA提供的能力
如何将应用集成
到KUSHA
可以分为两步
第一步
就是先定义
一个应用的
镜像模板
第二步
就可以直接通过
KUSHA API
去发起应用的任务
具体
我们也在官方当中
有一个文档
去介绍
如何去进行
应用的介入
下面我简单介绍一下
流程
首先要定一个IP image
IP image里面
主要是包含了三部分
一个是配置模板
一个是部署信息
以及镜像信息
我们先看一下
部署信息
其实就是
告诉KUSHA
应用
它要以什么样的方式
进行拉起来
比如说
它的命令行参数是什么
然后配置文件
要挂在哪一个目录
以及它需要的
网络的端口
是什么样的
然后
镜像信息指的是说
这个应用
它具体用的镜像的
版本是什么
除了部署信息
和镜像信息以外
还有一个叫配置模板
因为应用正常
它运行起来的时候
配置是非常重要的
所以在镜像信息
这个配置当中
可以描述
应用之间的一些
网络通信的地址
以及说应用
它具体执行的时候
它需要的一些配置
比如说这个应用
假设它有
要支持多个算子
那我当前
跑这个应用的时候
我应该跑的是
哪一个算子
然后这个算子
所需要的一些参数
是什么样的
都可以在配置文件
里边去描述
这个项目的时候
来库沙会将这个
配置文件
会渲染到
这个配置文件里边
然后将这个配置文件
会挂载到
应用具体指定的
这个配置目录里边
那我们先简单看一下
这个配置模板
要怎么去写
配置模板
其实它主要是会有
就是它首先
一个是
要配置一个模板
另外一个就是
这个模板里边
它可以定义一些
占卫服
然后这些占卫服
一部分是通过
用户去输入得到的
库沙自己
编排出来的
一些网络信息
比如说
像这里边的一个例子
就是
其中的蓝色部分
比如说
我们用这个task input
config这样的
一个占卫服去预留
那
其中这个
红色部分
是用这种
像task class的define
以及这个allocated
poss
还去预留
这个红色部分
就是
因为库沙内部
会做一些网络的编排
那一些网络的信息
比如说对方
它的地址
通信地址
以及本方的一些
端口的绑定
都是可以通过
库沙的网络编排来去定义的
用户只需要定义
一个这个模板
具体在执行任务的时候
这些
关于网络的
实际的纸
都是由库沙
去进行炫热的
加上一些输入的值
就可以组成
一个炫热后的一个配轮键
我们可以看一下
右侧这张图
比如说它这里边的
蓝色部分
也就是用户在
通过库沙API
在创建库沙照布的时候
会添入的一些信息
比如说
它这次执行的算法是什么
然后它的学习率
然后它的最大迭代次数
这些都是用户
它在页面上
由用户
人工的方式去设置的
这部分内容
是通过库沙API
去传递进来的
然后由库沙
进行渲染
到具体的配置文件里边
下面这个红色部分
其实就是
描述了
应用之间
它的通信
网络
端口
一些信息
这些是自动渲染的
定义完这个
App image
以及定义完
这个配置模板之后
就进入到了
通过库沙API
来创建库沙照本
先看一下
左侧这张图
也就是
在创建库沙照本
当中的库沙Task的时候
会指定一个
叫App image的一个名字
这个App image的名字
其实就是
我们上面介绍的
我们在定义App image的时候
会给它定义一个名字
然后
第二部分
这个蓝色部分
我们说的是
通过库沙API去传递的
这部分
具体的
用户
它在
左侧这边
库沙API去调用的时候
它会传递给库沙
传递给库沙之后
它具体经过的步骤
我们可以简单看一下
第一个是
库沙这边会根据
App image的名字
去找到具体的配置模板
部署信息
还有镜像信息
然后
会将这个
配置模板拿到之后
然后
再将这个库沙API当中的
这个蓝色部分
以及网络
组网的一些部分的内容
会渲染到配置文件里边
然后拿到一个
就是渲染后的一个配置文件内容
然后
第三步会根据
镜像的信息
会拉取这个应用的形象
那如果本地有的话
就不需要再去远程拉取了
这是第三步
然后第四步呢
会根据这个
应用的镜像
会拉起具体的容器
然后会将
渲染好的这个配置文件
会挂载到指定的目录
然后应用呢
它就在运行的时候
就可以从这个目录上
拿到就是
库沙渲染的这样的一个配置文件
然后应用就可以通过
这个配置文件里边
传递的信息
然后去执行主逻辑
然后以及通过这个
库沙进行的
网络编排
进行一些网络通信
完成这个任务
对 所以
将应用对接到库沙就分
主要就是两步
第一步是定义
iPad image
第二步就是通过库沙API
去创建这个库沙罩
那我们对本小节
做了一个总结
就是用户可以通过
库沙API的方式
去定制自己的隐私基金平台
那也可以将自己的应用
接入到库沙当中
来加速应用的交付
OK
那我今天主要分享的内容
就这么多
再简单
我们回顾一下
就是第一部分
我们介绍了
为什么会需要库沙
其实库沙就是希望能够
加速应用
从开发到生产
这些东西
所以我们在库沙的内容
就这么多
我们在库沙的内容
所以就是
可以对接库沙API
然后基于言语生态
开发到生产
的这样的一个交付的过程
然后解决一些
就是第二部分介绍了一下
就是库沙
解决的一些
从开发到交付
可能遇到的一些共性的问题
然后第三部分介绍了一些
就是如何
就是可以通过
拿几种方式来去使用库沙
好的
谢谢大家